[Music]
what the [ __ ] was i gonna say
um oh lord let's get into this
relationship advice
oh yeah oh yeah this one this one's this
one yes this one is very
very special very poignant do you wanna
do you wanna read the
the title sure how do i
22f make my boyfriend 23m
understand that he can't drop out of law
school to be a full-time podcaster
you can read it get into it here's the
thing i don't
we don't have to because yeah you can
you can you can
you can take it from us man you can you
can
you can do it i wouldn't even go as far
as saying do it
yeah yeah we're we're [ __ ] idiots and
we did it
uh you can do it man you can definitely
do it
[Laughter]
it's gotta be the worst advice ever
what yeah do it for us just to be like
do it do it do it
no you won't you won't do it actually i
don't think you'll do it [ __ ]
oh you wanna you wanna go to law school
you wanna go the safe route risk it all
man throw it all away
throw away all that hard work have some
cajones
[Laughter]
leave the what are you going to work for
some suits in a lot
right looking contracts what are you
going to do participating society
[ __ ]
loser loser you need some milk yeah
[Laughter]
you need to be you need to be
30 years old joking about old vine memes
digitally yeah that's what you got to be
doing
yeah bro um so okay so they've been
this is in in her voice the f's voice
whenever i see like a single f i just
can't not think of twitch
so it's like 22f i just think of like a
22 year old who like needs respect it's
like 22f
[Laughter]
like giving multiple respects here are
22 f's
which is so dumb that's really funny
actually 22f
yeah oh my man 22f for you
22. i really support you 22f
i'm not going to sub but i'll give you
22 apps 22 f's man yeah that's for me to
eat
yeah all right uh dude wait a [ __ ]
dad streaming and everyone in the chat
is just going
typing poggers and f and he gets all
offended
why do you guys keep typing f why are
you effing me
what did i do yeah f you guys
yeah yeah oh now it's more f's
yeah oh wow now what 22 22 f's cool wow
f
f you guys back yeah
deplorable this [ __ ] website you kids
they're like dude we're just trying to
show you respect that's respect to you
guys
[Laughter]
no dad it's like a it's like a it's like
a reference
to a game yeah that's it never mind
all right so 22f says they've been
together for two years
i moved 1200 kilometers uh what is that
like 10 feet
yeah 10 feet to be with how many how
many liters is that
um i don't know like
two like two
i moved 22 kilometers to be with him
in february that's really wait wait
the wall 1200 dude you said 22.
oh no it's 12 yeah 1200 yeah sorry 22
kilometers
i moved 27 literally five blocks i moved
like three blocks
i moved 1200 kilometers to be with him
in february and things were great until
may
when my boyfriend and his friends
started a sports podcast
all right at first was just a hobby my
boyfriend is a big podcast nerd so
it was really nice to see him do
something he liked so much
but then he started getting more and
more invested and stopped watching his
remote classes studying
studying to dedicate his full time to
his podcast
he's seriously considering dropping out
of law school because he can't
concentrate on
both studying and running a podcast and
he would rather do what he loves
man come on whoever wrote this i can't
wait for your book to come out
which would be fine if what he loved
wasn't a two month old podcast
it was barely 30 listeners damn
give him a chance wow and the same
content of at least 100 other podcasts
that's just mean you gotta you gotta try
and understand what he's going for
yeah yeah give him a chance on top of
that his parents
who pay our rent are threatening to cut
us off if he goes through with this
oh he just says his parents that's rough
you said what
that's rough for him yeah yeah he just
says his parents are going to take us in
but i don't really want
to live with my parent in laws and i'm
an intern at a
in a big i'm an intern in a big
expensive city i can't pay rent with my
wages
can't [ __ ] off back to my town due to
coveted restrictions and even if i could
i don't have the money
so really how do i convince him this is
the worst idea ever i tried reasoning
explaining but he really believes
they're gonna break through
they're good but it's just not easy to
make a living out of these things
oh man that's that's actually this is
tough
yeah it's actually pretty brutal
you know the fact that like she just
can't get on board
yeah exactly she's like
let's talk about who is in the wrong
here yeah you want to talk about wrong
yeah her yeah
i stand with my my podcast presents my
gay and solidarity we gotta root for our
boy
and just by default just be you know
you're wrong
you're just toxic just straight up wrong
he will break through
and they are good okay okay okay look
all right look look look look
so what there's a couple other sports
podcasts
a couple of them it's like it's like two
it's like espn
and ufc oh maybe the nba
yeah what else it's like just it's like
three or four
there's room for another one another
thing is that
he's got more sorry go ahead no i was
gonna say how do you actually
convince this dude do you think like
what what do you what do you actually
convince this dude with
i i don't know if this is your boy this
is your boy and you're like
oh man you're trying to prevent him from
making a
really potentially bad decision
what do you mean this is your friend
yeah if it's like if this is if this is
your boy this is your podcast bro from
one podcast bro to another
how do you convince him hey man
don't this might be a bad idea i don't
know like she said she tried reasoning
with him that's the only thing i would
say is sit him down and be like dude you
really you're gonna go live with your
parents again so you can podcast
you realize how absurd that [ __ ]
sounds this is a hobby
it it and it's and make it a hobby it's
a great [ __ ] hobby but you can do
both two things at once
if you really want to do this and it
really is a passion of yours don't make
it your full-time thing until you
actually have evidence
that this will take off because right
now there's no evidence 30
listeners is nothing you know maybe when
she says reasoning with him
maybe she might be focusing too much on
the
reality in that she might focusing too
much on there are other podcasts
and you're just another one in the mix
and that just invalidates you know you
might be getting defensive like well
you don't believe in me you know versus
what you're saying which i think is the
way to go where you go hey man
how much money do you make from this if
you stick with law school how much you
going to make from that
all right which one is going to provide
guaranteed
yeah yeah yeah but when you're 23 like
you don't really give a [ __ ] about
providing for anyone you're just like
that's true
yeah he's gonna do whatever it takes to
make this dream happen
which which people tell you to do that's
another thing is that that's
that's a widely accepted idea is do
whatever it takes to make
what your passion is come to life but i
just feel like when it's at the expense
of like other people
like there's a way you can do it yeah
like i said if you really want to make
it work
do two jobs bro i'll never forget
this [ __ ] brutal clip um
from the the kill tony show um
when they would they would upload uh
part of the podcast is
is uh someone doing like a like one
minute on stage like kind of open it's
like an open mic they like do a raffle
and they let some comics come up and do
a minute of material
and hold on to the live show um
kill tony yeah yeah okay roast
um comedy store dude i feel so
bad that i'm forgetting this dude's name
uh he's the host of the rose battle uh
oh
jeff ross no no not jeff ross is it uh
here we here we go here we go
no no yeah brian moses
brian moses um he's comedian
forever host of the rose battle i
believe it was him
so this dude gets up there and he does a
minute and it's not
a super sharp minute okay and then
they're like where are you from dude
he's like i moved here
from such and such and uh he either
moved to la or he had
uh it was like a bunch of money or he
had been living in l.a and he just quit
his job to pursue comedy
and right away brian moses i want to say
it was him he was like
uh yeah just word of advice guys um
don't quit your jobs it's like he's like
comedy takes time
in fact a job is a good thing because
you could take that money
and you could put you in a writing class
you can you can spend that money on
things to get you better
uh with your creativity yeah
he's like because at least if you have a
job and you're bombing open mics
then you still have a job but you don't
have a job then you're just
unemployed bombing open mics yeah
it was like some brutal comparison like
that and i just like
wait they were listening the guys had
just done that the guy's just sitting
there on stage like oh
okay and the whole room is just like
ow ow
wake-up call
yeah so no but i bring that up because
what you're saying is so true i feel
like that
blanket like oh pursue your dreams
you know it's like there's a time to
give up everything
but i feel like right away no like you
have to
to that same end uh
i think it's on twitch or like i was
reading something about like like some
[ __ ] twitter thread it's basically
about like blowing up
and like you know the sentiment was like
oh i want to like pop off
yeah and we've talked about this before
but i saw that and
it's like no like you don't want that
you don't want like the
instant [ __ ] like i feel like
everything is always
presented in extremes you don't want to
[ __ ] explode
and you don't want to just give up
everything like gradual is good
yep yeah the only the only case that i
that i think that i can think of where
that actually worked is call or daddy
yeah they blew the [ __ ] up and then
normally when you blow up that fast
to taper off is just as steep yeah
whereas if you grow slowly
it it you know it generally sticks
around a little bit but
here's the thing with podcasts how do
you how do you even blow up
with a podcast starting from scratch you
can't
like even when even with us when we were
very like starting
right at the beginning and even with me
with insanely chill it's like i already
had a pretty sizable youtube audience
that you know drove traffic to the
podcast i have no idea how the [ __ ]
yeah you would you would a blow up when
starting from scratch
just audio podcasts yeah and be
why you would think that you would yeah
i mean like like there's
no like viral sharing mechanics like
built into the podcast it's just
literally word of mouth that's got to be
the slowest way
to grow i mean people have done it for
sure but because
yeah with like a viral clip even if you
have like a clip go crazy on your pod
dude take the [ __ ] breakfast club
when like birdman
walked out that was like a crazy viral
thing how many people saw that and were
like
man i'm gonna tune in at at whatever
time to listen to this hour-long show
for the potential of a 60-second no one
does that
you know they might they might go watch
because they could very easily go
oh man it looks hilarious and they go
watch the full clip and they can go oh
this is boring
yeah i don't care about this yeah um but
yeah
even to this day when people like ask
like oh how did you get the podcast
where it was like we don't
we don't really have like a definitive
answer yeah it's literally just
i mean i yeah we just i don't know
you just keep doing it i guess yeah but
it's also like we had a head start
yeah right at the beginning we had
people that were watching because
we had worked on growing an audience but
you know on youtube
that's an easy thing to do easier than
podcast because
youtube has all the you know they'll
push your video people are watching it
yeah you have like an engine behind you
mm-hmm that's helping you
i feel like this is a good thing to
discuss because i feel that there are a
lot of people that hit us up and say
like oh i want to start a podcast but i
don't know where to begin
and i think if the only thing i feel
that we can nail down for sure about
when we made when we started ours is i
think uh
by doing it like at your place and
uh my [ __ ] apartment and like
like just doing it in a natural setting
i feel like that
above anything [ __ ] all the equipment
and all that that [ __ ] does not matter
i mean it does but just make it
listenable but like just
keep it keep it true to you i feel like
people sniff that out before anything
before the quality if the [ __ ] feels
just super like fake and
forced people tune out from that so they
want to hear that
yeah so anyway um i have to shout out my
sister's podcast now
yeah go for it the the time the
dietitian project
on on apple podcast or wherever you
consume your podcast
she's been doing this now for she's got
16 episodes
okay okay and she does this like outside
of her job she'll write these
like they're really good like really
good sick
for people that want to be nutritionists
or dietitians
or uh it's a podcast where she has real
gritty and honest conversations about
the role of a dietitian and provide
practical empowering advice for finding
your passion within the field
if that interests you go check it out
smash it i think that's the cool thing
about podcast was definitely one for
like everything